Đất nền Sồi Đầu, Tân Hộ Tân Già, Mất Độ Già đang hội phục hai chứng xuống ảo trong sống tăng đầu năm 2019.
Thì chương bất đậu sạm Việt Nam khi nhận hơn hai chăm mấy bế lắm nền Sáo Dịch, chủ yếu là đến nền, cho thế giấu hiệu phục hồi sống thời gian chăm lắng.
Dó các nổ tại Hân Đội và thành phố Hồ Chí Minh, tiếp được tăng mạnh, tập biệt ở các quận chung tâm và phục vèn của pháp đi sợ sàng tiện ít hoàn thiệt.
Trong khi đó, nên hành hộ của dấu hiệu chính là nhiều thành phố Hồ Chí Minh, nhất là khu bực nhà bệnh tránh của đồng Vất Sồi Đầu, mới hút tăng bộ nền Sáo Vinh Giang.
Theo phát triên ra, tị trơn năm 2018, tìm vọng vừa lợi từ quả trình đồ thiệu ngoá và các chiến sách vách trị tình phủ vệ tình.
Tuy bệnh, tị trơn, bất đậu mắt dấu mắt dấu sáo càng, ra nhất đất tại hai tình phố lượng đã tăng gấp bà đến năm 2019.
Bất gia đứa lập trung viện tình khoảng gà.
Hoa ra phần lửa nơi gần gấp tổng sả đặc biệt nhỏ vừa vừa vừa nhỏ của năng lực tại Chí Giú,
là có trong tiếp gặp bồn sợ tình xúc bị sien, người mua ngay tạm tự trọc, chỉ còn tâm để sự an pháp liên mình bài trung đồ tư,
vừa tình. Tình hiểu tích cực là từ ngày buồn sáng bây, là mấy ngày buồn sáng hai lắm,
các đúng mắt pháp liên sẽ được tháo gỡ theo nghị quyết hai lệm một tạo đu kiện phát triển nhà ở sả hội,
đời nháng phía sê tự án vào buồn sĩ quyết đắt phố hợp, của mời lại xuất phay sáp và sự liệu sáng nhà đất mình bài trung
khi chúng ông được khi vọng sẽ phục hồi bình bự xung thử ra tự.